hello everyone it's seven o'clock Jeremy
Hunt has defended his budget as a plan
for growth to get people back to work as
he faced accusations of handing some of
the country's wealthiest people a one
billion pound tax giveaway I'll press
the chance long plan Point by point and
he joins me in a few minutes time
labor have called on the government to
think again saying that they'll reverse
the pension's tax break if they gain
power at the next election the shadow
Chancellor Rachel Reeves joins me later
in the program it's Thursday the 16th of
March
the wrong priority for the wrong people
labor says it will reverse Jeremy Hunt's
pension reforms as the chancellor
defends his budget as a plan for growth
the banking giant credit suisses to
borrow 45 billion pounds from the Swiss
Central Bank after its shares plunged
yesterday
passengers face disruption again on the
railways as a fresh wave of walkouts by
the rnt bring many services to a
standstill
the foreign secretary heads to Moldova
promising more UK support for the
country against Russia's influence
potential buyers queue up for a look
around Manchester United with a visit
expected today from qatar's Sheikh
jasime
[Music]
and the R B singer Bobby Caldwell best
known for this 1978 hit What You Won't
Do for Love has died at the age of 71.
[Music]
thank you
hello good morning labor says it will
reverse Jeremy Hunt's plans to scrap the
lifetime allowance for pensions if it
comes to power at the next election the
new rules will allow High earners to
save more money into their pensions
tax-free labor says the plan will help
the wealthy few but the chancellor has
defended his budget which he says will
have a transformational effect on the
economy here's a reminder of some of the
key announcements
well the UK is expected to avoid
recession this year with forecasts that
inflation will fall to 2.9 percent by
the end of 2023.
for households the energy price
guarantee will continue until June with
energy bills remaining at two and a half
thousand pounds cap
fuel Duty including the five pence a
liter cut will be extended and beer Duty
has also been frozen
30 hours of free child care a week will
be available to working parents in
England for children aged between nine
months and five years
for Lifetime allowance the total amount
that people can save into their pension
pot before paying extra cash has been
scrapped and the pension's annual
tax-free allowance Will Rise by 50
percent
for business a nine billion pound full
expensing scheme will let firms who
invest in I.T plant or Machinery deduct
the cost info from their taxable profits
well let's continue to the with the
budget talk to the man who delivered it
I'm joined now by the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt good to talk to you this morning Mr
Hunt if you don't have a child on the
way or a pension pot over a million
Pounds what's in this budget for you
well good morning Jane a great deal
because we introduced help for people
struggling with cost of living pressures
that amount to 3 300 pounds for the
typical household uh over this year and
last year we've extended the energy
price guarantee at two and a half
thousand pounds for another three months
we've frozen fuel Duty which will keep
the cost of petrol down and what we are
doing is we're helping people through a
very very difficult period but we're
also tackling as you mentioned just then
the long-term issues facing the economy
which is that we have a million
vacancies up and down the country and we
want to remove the barriers that stop
people from working and the biggest area
of concern for us is the NHS where
doctors have been retiring early that's
meaning that we have these long waiting
lists seven million people on the
waiting list and so we've announced
measures that will tackle those head-on
who are on over a hundred thousand
pounds really the problem isn't it
fundamentally the problem that we need
more nurses
well we need uh more nurses and we we
are recruiting many more nurses into the
NHS but yes um I think if you can talk
to anyone in the NHS they will say
doctors leaving the workforce because of
pension rules is a big problem
um it's something incidentally that
labor advocated last September uh where
streeting said that we should get rid of
the cap on pensions the lifetime
allowance he seems to have changed his
mind overnight on that one he said it
was crazy and it would save lives to get
rid of that cap well he's he was right
in September when he said that the
British Medical Association program
those points to them but you say you
really are helping people but but after
13 years of a conservative government
we've got teachers doctors transport
workers all out on strike even your own
civil servants are on strike analysts
have said that by freezing income tax in
the budget yesterday you're effectively
adding 4p to income tax for around 6
million people that's from the obr
people are losing money and the obr says
it's going to get worse before it gets
better this isn't a budget for the
people
well we had to help people in the
pandemic we spent 400 billion pounds
helping businesses and families we're
spending nearly 100 billion pounds
helping families with cost of living
pressures because of the energy crisis
we have to be honest with people that
has an impact on our accounts will
always be responsible with people's
money and we want to help people through
a difficult period but we want to go on
the path to lower taxes as conservatives
one of the things that's happened in the
last year for the first time ever in
this country you can earn a thousand
pounds a month without paying a penny of
tax or national insurance so
conservatives will always bring taxes
down when we can but when people are
going through difficult periods as they
are now with these huge increases in
energy bills of course we want to help
people
but you've only got 18 months to to
bring in these tax cuts of which we've
not seen any in this budget I mean is it
enough to catch up labor before the next
election that there's you know some 20
points ahead are you not concerned that
an 18 months time the narratives of the
conservatives crashing the economy is
still going to be at the front of
everyone's mind this isn't bold enough
well well I think um if you look at the
measures I announced yesterday which are
removing the barriers for thousands
hundreds of thousands of parents who are
struggling to get back to work because
of child care
don't cut in child care costs that's
nearly 60 percent I think the one thing
people wouldn't say Jane is that it's
not bold in terms of its ambition we
want to remove the barriers that stop
people who want to from working by the
way there's a huge package in there for
long-term sick and disabled because we
think with the potential of working from
home Zoom teams the idea that because
you have a disability means you you
shouldn't be able to work or you can't
work we think that's very outdated and
we're going to get rid of the work
capability assessment and give people
support to help them get back into work
so this is I think a budget that helps
businesses fill their vacancies sorry
carry on it's just about the speed it's
just not fast enough I mean the child
care plans you know if you've got a
nine-month-old baby you're not going to
benefit from these because your baby
will be three or four by the time it
kicks in or if you have a three-year-old
baby it'll be five by the time it kicks
in in fact it's only people who are
thinking about getting pregnant now who
are going to benefit from this it's not
going to have kicked in by the next
election and it's going to take three
years to organize wrap around child care
for schools why on Earth does it take so
long to sort out kids clubs
well this is the biggest transformation
in child care in my lifetime Jane it's a
huge change and we're going to need
thousands more nurseries thousands more
schools offering provision they don't
currently offer thousands more child
minders we are going as fast as we can
get the supply in the market to expand
but it's the right thing to do because
we have one of the most expensive Child
Care Systems in the world and we know
that it's something that's a huge worry
for women in particular that they have
this Cliff Edge when maternity leave
ends after nine months no help until the
child turns three and that can often be
career ending so I think it's the right
thing to do for many many women to
introduce these reforms and we are
introducing them as quickly as we can
because we want to remove those barriers
to work by the way that's also very good
for business which is why yesterday's
measures were welcomed by the main
business organizations like the CBI
they've been saying for for some time
now that child care is causing a big
problem for businesses who are losing
staff when they really need them the
most
but but analysts have also said yes it's
great that business is having investment
but one thing that you didn't mention
yesterday was public sector pay and and
you you need to invest in business but
you also need to invest invest in the
public sector why do you not think these
two things run side by side
well they do and that's why in the
Autumn statement we announced an eight
billion pound package for the NHS and
social care system the three billion
pound package for our schools those pay
negotiations are happening now
um I think they seem to be making
encouraging progress we'll wait for news
but we're we want to solve them as
quickly as we can and that's why we're
having those discussions
you made it really clear that
yesterday's budget was all about getting
people back to work why do you think
fewer people came back to work in the UK
after covert than they did in in Europe
and the rest of the world and we have so
many people on long term sick why do you
think this is has the UK got a
particular problem with laziness
I don't think that at all I think people
in this country work extremely hard but
um and if you look at what's happened
over the last 13 years since we've been
in power unemployment has halved we have
two million more disabled people in work
we have a you know an employment level
at 76 percent that's fairly normal for
advanced economies but if we had the
employment levels they have in Holland
for example we would have 2.7 million
more people in work so we could fill
every vacancy nearly three times over
and that's why we recognize when we want
to boost growth to generate more tax
revenues for our NHS and our schools
that we need to remove the barriers that
stop for example young parents from
going back to work when they have
children
do we need more immigration the obr has
pointed out that a quarter of a million
people are expected to come to the UK
this year do you think that that
fundamentally is something we need to be
focusing on
well I think the decision of the British
people in the brexit referendum was that
we want an economic model that does not
depend on unlimited low-skilled
migration and um do you think that's why
yesterday
well that's why I want to change that
and that's why yesterday I set about
systematically removing the barriers not
just young parents worried about child
care costs but job Seekers older people
long-term sick and disabled those four
groups of people where there are lots of
people who face barriers to work and we
want to take away those barriers so that
we don't have an economy that is
dependent on unlimited migration
okay one final question before I let you
go because now you've got lots of other
interviews to do Credit Suisse How
concerned should we be about what is
happening there are you worried about
contagion in British Banks
well as you know Jane chancellors never
comment on what's happening in the
markets
um obviously I'm following the situation
the governor of the bank of England is
following it very closely I think the
news we've heard from the Swiss
authorities this morning is encouraging
but I won't say any more than that
Jeremy Hunt very good he's talked to us
thanks a lot for joining us
thank you
when I'm joined Now by our business
correspondent gurpreet now on uh gopreet
we're now had a little bit of time to
digest what happened in the budget
yesterday uh for example what are the
obr saying yeah it was a big budget then
I think many people were expecting and
the obr assessment of the economy was a
little bit brighter than its last
forecast but I'm afraid that much of the
good news ends there because although
Jeremy Hunt made a very big deal about
the fact that the country has avoided a
technical recession for most Ordinary
People it won't make much difference to
their living standards the office for
Budget responsibility and its assessment
said yesterday that the country is still
on course our disposable incomes are
still on course for their biggest
two-year decline since the 1950s not
going to give us much cause to celebrate
there and that's partly because of
inflation we know inflation is our
eroding our spending power but it's also
because of taxes the tax burden is at a
post-war High some of those taxes you
might know about but some of them have
been quietly introduced and we haven't
really been aware of them stealth taxes
that's because the government has frozen
tax thresholds it means more people are
being dragged into higher rates of tax
and we think that's going to raise the
government about 120 billion pounds over
the course of the next five years so I'm
asking that instead of offering uh you
know a big tax cut to the higher earners
and older workers through the pension
system why Jeremy Hunt didn't move on
that but while taxes are going up Public
Services real real-time spending for
public services unprotected budgets is
actually being cut where essentially
being asked to pay more for less and the
reason for that is quite simply because
we don't have enough economic growth in
the country so it doesn't give the
chancellor much room to do either
thanks a lot uh well time now to take a
look at this morning's papers let's
start with the financial times its
headline hunt defies Gloom with upbeat
budget
the Metro calls the announcement the
Easy Does It budget
the express is in an upbeat mood
declaring will make this work for
Britain
the news that fuel a duty is to stay
frozen Sparks the headline in the sun
tanks a lot
the guardian's verdict is damning the
paper describes it as a giveaway for the
one percent
likewise the mirror headline there pots
for the rich
the eye says that what we've actually
seen is a full pence in the pound income
Rise by stealth
and on the same theme the time says we
now have the biggest tax burden since
the war
well as we were talking about just there
one of Europe's biggest banks Credit
Suisse has secured a 45 billion pound
loan from Switzerland's Central Bank its
hoped alone will Shore up the bank's
finances after a share price plunged
yesterday
this morning stock markets across Asia
have fallen after the ftse 100 had 75
billion pounds wiped off its value
yesterday and the worst day of trading
for a year the turmoil has added to
concerns about the broader banking
sector after Silicon Valley Bank and
Signature Bank to mid-sized firms in the
U.S collapsed last week
or still to come on the show as rail
strikes once again bring train services
to a halt across much of the country
I'll talk to the r t Union general
secretary Mick Lynch
I'll also be talking to Lord West former
head of the royal Navy and former
security minister to get his reaction to
the defense spending measures in the
budget
and it just after half past eight I'll
be joined by the shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves for Labor's response to
budget and the Chancellor's comments
this morning
[Music]
strike by rail workers from the rmt
union will bring train services to a
halt across the country today in the
latest disruption caused by a wave of
industrial action Sky correspondent Saba
choudhary joins me now from London's
Houston Station uh Saba this is having a
significant impact in this area isn't it
good morning yes it is yesterday it was
London Underground staff striking and
today it's members of the rmt Union
minus those from Network rail I should
say who are currently considering a pale
pay offer now what this means in
practice is around 40 to 50 of trains
will just be operating today the
majority of those impacted services in
England although there are I should say
Regional differences to be considered
now
those striking yesterday and those
striking today really their message is
one of the same they want the same thing
better pay working conditions and job
security but nine months on in this
long-going dispute and strike action we
are seeing we're at a stalemate this is
something that we haven't seen much
movement on the government have very
recently offered what they're calling
their best and final offer two members
of the rnt Union which is a five percent
back dated pay rise from last year and a
four percent pay rise this year now Nick
Lynch the leader of the rmt Union who is
here on the picket line uh has said
frankly as he often does that this is a
dreadful offer one that he put to his
members and they're simply not happy
with and that's because it comes with
strings attached for them to accept this
offer the government say they have to
accept some changes they want to make to
the railways to to modernize them but
Mick Lynch's Union at the rmt are saying
that it's not good enough and they want
an unconditional payoffer and until they
get that they all strike today they will
strike on Saturday 30th of March and
also the first of April Saba thanks very
much
well let's take a look at today's
strikes and others coming up later this
month as well as today Royal workers
have two more strike days planned on
Saturday and Thursday the 30th of March
teachers are on day two of a national
strike while ambulance staff represented
by unite Union walk out on the 20th
driving examiners and University staff
also have multiple days of strikes
planned
more than 350 Amazon workers are also
striking today in a row overpay the GMB
union members in Coventry are asking for
a rise from 10 pounds 50 an hour to 15
pounds after causing a calling a five
percent offered arisery Amazon doesn't
recognize the union and won't enter pay
negotiations with its Representatives
now Sky News understands that after more
than a week of intense negotiations
Health unions and the government are
getting closer to agreeing a pay deal to
avert further strikes in the NHS
progress on the long-running dispute
which has led to unprecedented walkouts
by nurses and ambulance workers means a
potential pay deal could be announced as
soon as today it's not clear though
whether union members would accept the
terms when they're balloted
foreign secretary James cleverley is
visiting Moldova today to pledge
financial support as the country comes
under pressure from Russian influence
Moldova borders Ukraine where the war
against the Russian invasion has now
been raging for more than a year along
that eastern border is transnistria an
unrecognized Breakaway State supported
economically and militarily by Moscow
the US has suggested there are
indications that Russia wants to build a
land bridge through Ukraine to
transnistria
foreign
secretary will meet his moldovan
counterpart before announcing new
financial aid to boost efforts to
prevent Russian interference we're
expecting that visit through the morning
and we'll bring you more on it here on
Skinny's breakfast
and to Manchester United now and
representatives of the Qatari Baker
Sheikh jasim are expected to visit Old
Trafford today with the ineas founder
sir Jim Radcliffe heading there tomorrow
as the two prepare rival bids to buy the
club well our Sports correspondent Rob
Harris is here with me uh Rob does this
mean that the current owners the Glazer
family are ready to sell well there are
still questions whether they really will
sell the club it was in November they
announced they were looking at what they
called strategic options looking for new
financing anything up to a sale so they
launched this process with the rain
banking Merchant Bank based in New York
and it led to a month ago bids coming in
we only know two known bids from Jake's
Shea Jackson bin Hamad and from Sir Jim
Radcliffe there could be others we also
know the financing offer from a group
called Elliot and what we don't know yet
is is the price acceptable we don't know
the price that officially that's on the
table potentially around four and a half
billion might value The Club at the
offers coming in at and the glazers
might want in excess of five six billion
pounds for the club they've owned since
2005. the fans are desperate for an end
of the Glazer's ownership the heavy debt
the state of Old Trafford we're seeing
there the protests that have been raging
Glazer out that have been running even
since the day they bought the club in
2005 they want more spending they want
the Glory Days back they want to be
winning the Premier League again which
they haven't done so since 2013. so as
it stands now the potential new owners
are going to be looking around the club
they're going to be at the training
ground they're going to be going through
the books the finances the commercial
deals the player contracts to see just
how much is the club worth so they can
put the actual bid in to see if it's
acceptable and we've got on the one side
this offer linked to Qatar from the
Qatari Islamic Bank chairman Sheikh
Jason bin Ahmad the son of a former
prime minister with links to The
Sovereign wealth as well there although
they say it's not a state project and
then on the other side the locally
balancing Radcliffe who made his fortune
through iniosu also has investments in
other sports so wait to see the outcome
of those presentations friends I mean
more delegates for football's
international governing body FIFA are
meeting today they're gathering for the
organization's annual Congress um in the
Rwandan Capital what are we expecting to
come out of that well we're expecting
Johnny fantina to be re-elected free for
president to turn that began in 2016.
he's also found a way of the rules
allowing him to go beyond potential
terminals until 2031. many remember him
from the start of the World Cup in Qatar
when he gave that slightly strange
speech there I am Qatari I'm a migrant
worker when he was trying to defend the
polite of qataris and attack hypocrisy
he's come under a lot of criticism for
some of his leadership of world football
he has grown the revenue several billion
pounds is expecting more than 9 billion
pounds in Revenue in the next cycle up
to the 2026 World Cup but he is under a
criminal investigation in Switzerland
over unauthorized meetings allegedly
with the undisclosed meetings allegedly
with the attorney general so there are
questions as well over just how his sort
of LED World football the pursuit of
more money whether it's needed and
questions as we approach the Women's
World Cup in Australia New Zealand this
year over prize money the fact is not
equal with the men's very distant from
it and also over a visit Saudi
sponsorship of that tournament that's
had a backlash from players and the host
Nations okay Rob thanks very much let's
take a look at some of the day's other
headlines now and a 29 year old man has
been charged with attempted murder after
a woman was stabbed outside a Leisure
Center in Cheltenham last Thursday
police say that Joanna Bowles from
Welland news in Cheltenham also faces a
charge of causing actual bodily harm and
will appear at Westminster magistrates
Court later today
yeah dozens of firefighters have been
battling Ablaze at a centuries-old hotel
in Midhurst in West Sussex where
Ukrainian refugees are said to have been
staying Sussex police say that they are
assisting the fire and rescue service
there's not yet been any reports of
casualties
the UK is slipping down the global ranks
on life expectancy in 2021 we came 29th
according to researchers in Oxford and
London but 70 years ago the UK was
seventh the analysis finds that since
then we've fared worse than all other G7
Nations except the USA the current life
expectancy is 79 years for men and
nearly 83 years for women
thank you
artificial sweeteners often used in hot
drinks could apparently suppress
immunity according to new research a
high amount of sucralose lowers the
activation of a type of white blood cell
in animals and could have a similar
effect in humans this means the
sweetener could eventually be used as a
treatment for people with autoimmune
disorders
agent has said he thought the match of
the day presenter believed he had a
special agreement with the BBC to tweet
about refugees and immigration writing
in the new Statesman John Holmes said
his client takes a passionate interest
in the issue
now it's been quite a spiky start to the
visit of politicians from the north and
south of Ireland to Washington the dup
leader Sir Jeffrey Donaldson said the
top Democrat in the U.S Senate Chuck
Schumer needs to read up on his history
after urging the dup to go back to
Stormont from there our Island
correspondent Stephen Murphy reports
it's that time of the year again in
Washington the Irish leader rubbing
shoulders with the most powerful figures
in U.S politics this St Patrick's week
the Hot Topic is the Windsor framework
and whether it can be changed to appease
the dup and get storm and back up and
running so will it be reworked or
changed
uh like I I understand the question that
you're asking me but this is a very
sensitive moment uh in this process
um it's not for me to speak for other
people
um what's happened is we have an
agreement at long last between the UK uh
and the European commission ultimately
it's going to be a decision for the UK
prime minister as as to when the UK
decides to press ahead the dup who have
refused to facilitate the valve
government in Northern Ireland over the
protocol and now the Windsor framework
attend the same events in Washington
they often have to endure intense
pressure to fall into line from powerful
pro-irish figures like the most senior
politician in the Senate and now that
the Windsor framework has been announced
I sincerely hope that it clears the way
for the dup to join Shin Fein in a power
power sharing agreement I say to all
parties in the north but especially to
the dup let's get to the people's
business the dup doesn't take it lying
down I would urge the Senator to read
some history books and maybe he'll learn
a little bit more about what really
happens and the reality of the situation
the party's message here it wants Richie
sunac to make changes to his new deal
we're saying the government needs to go
further needs to dig deeper to ensure
that what we get is not only it not only
works for here and now but is future
proof but there's no appetite to change
the deal in London or Brussels so so for
now Washington is the sounding board for
the pro and anti-framework arguments
ahead of Leo varatker's meeting with Joe
Biden on St Patrick's Day this Friday
Stephen Murphy Sky News in Washington
the R B singer Bobby Caldwell has died
at the age of 71.
[Music]
1978 Is What You Won't Do for Love the
influential singer-songwriter Had A
Soulful voice and musical style that was
adored by generations of fellow artists
his wife Mary said he died but then New
Jersey home on Tuesdays following a long
illness
thing but you don't give up
let's go look at the weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
a series of low pressure systems
spreading in from the Atlantic
guarantees changeable conditions over
the coming days with outbreaks of rain
and some strong
windsori is moving in but the cold air
is never too far away
fairly mild and Breezy start to the day
with rain over much of Scotland and
Northern England the rain belt will
become slow moving resulting in some
significant rainfall totals in the west
shower outbreaks of rain over western
parts of the UK Mainland will push
eastwards through the morning
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
and with lots of parts of the world
experiencing extreme weather conditions
let's take a look at the impact of
climate change on the planet the right
half of the screen shows how the UK is
power is currently being produced on the
top left you can also see how much
warmer it is now on the earth than in
1880 that is when modern records began
and finally bottom left the total amount
of CO2 emissions in millions of tons
are you watching Sky News coming up
the newly discovered work from the
graffiti artist Banksy which may have
already been produced to Rubble
[Music]
now mural that appeared on the side of a
derelict building in Kent has been
confirmed as a Banksy but unfortunately
for fans of the graffiti artist or maybe
the owner of the home as well it may
already have been lost the anonymous
artists shared photographs on his
official Instagram account shows this
silhouette of a young boy but it's not
there anymore a company was accompanied
by a cat appearing to open a pair of
curtains from a first floor window now
just a pile of rubble uh was it was it
possibly removed we don't know but what
has left are huge chunks of the wall on
the ground it's not new known whether or
not that work has been preserved
well back to the budget and talking to
the program this morning the chancellor
has defended his budget against the
accusation that it mainly helps wealthy
pensioners Jeremy Hunt also said his
plans will help many people through a
difficult period and told me the changes
to child care will be the biggest
transformation seen in his lifetime a
great deal because we introduced help
for people struggling with cost of
living pressures that amount to 3 300
pounds for the typical household over
this year and last year we've extended
the energy price guarantee at two and a
half thousand pounds for another three
months we've frozen fuel Duty which will
keep the cost of petrol down and what we
are doing is we're helping people
through very very difficult period if
you've got a nine-month-old baby you're
not going to benefit from these because
your baby will be three or four by the
time it kicks in or if you have a
three-year-old baby it'll be five by the
time it kicks in in fact it's only
people who are thinking about getting
pregnant now who are going to benefit
from this it's not gonna have kicked in
by the next election and it's going to
take three years to organize wrap around
child care for schools why on Earth does
it take so long to sort out kids clubs
well this is the biggest transformation
in child care in my lifetime Jane it's a
huge change and we're going to need
thousands more nurseries thousands more
schools offering provision they don't
currently offer thousands more child
minders we are going as fast as we can
get the supply in the market to expand
or a political correspondent tomorrow
Cohen is here with me in the studio and
tomorrow I put it to him that it wasn't
really bold enough but he seems
confident that it is I think yesterday's
announcements were full of optimism but
then when you start looking at the
detail you wonder how many groups are
really going to benefit given this big
squeeze on living standards and the fact
that most people will be paying more tax
because of the Frozen thresholds
certainly one of the big groups that did
benefit yesterday in a bit of a surprise
was people with a lot of pension savings
because the chancellor lifted the
lifetime allowance so if currently if
you have a million pounds in your
pension you get penalized every time you
try and withdraw those savings at 55 the
chancellor announced that that would be
lifted not to a high level but gotten
rid of altogether he said it would help
senior doctors in their 50s who were
dropping out of the workforce because
they are being penalized for taking
money out of their pensions now
according to the um obr that's the
official forecaster statistics it might
bring about 15 10 000 people back into
the workforce but of course you may also
get some people who decide to drop out
earlier because they're allowed to save
more in their pensions so it could be um
you know giving with one hand and taking
away with another so it's been pointed
out that this measure which is pretty
expensive it's been costed at 1.2
billion pounds a year once it gets going
it's basically about 80 000 pounds for
each one of those people you bring back
to the workforce so and being described
as an interesting priority labor have
said this is the wrong priority at the
wrong time for the wrong people they
call it a tax cut for the top one
percent and they say they would reverse
it I think we can expect them to try and
force a vote on that in the next few
days okay tomorrow thanks very much
now a strike by rail workers today will
cause more disruption as members of the
rmt Union at 14 operators walk out and a
long-running dispute over pay and
conditions I'm joined now by the rmt's
general secretary Mick Lynch Mick Lynch
good to talk to you this morning can I
ask you what you thought of the budget
first of all was there anything in there
for you
no there's no move from the government
to solve these public sector pay
disputes there's certainly nothing
that we can recognize for the railway
and it seems to be a budget for the rich
uh and there'll be a continuous transfer
of wealth from working people because
the tax thresholds for ordinary workers
have not gone up but for the wealthy
they can put up to 60 000 pounds a year
into their pension scheme and they'll
have unlimited uh tax break on their
lifetime Journey so it seems A peculiar
pension A peculiar step to take where
you're giving more money to the wealthy
and taking money off the poor and that's
a transfer of wealth in our society
which we saw under list trust and
quasi-quarting and Jeremy Hunt's going
the same way it seems
let's move on to what's actually
happening today with you and the ongoing
strikes that the rail delivery group
says that the rmt has been offered nine
percent over two years and 13
specifically to the lowest paid workers
is that true and if so why haven't you
accepted it
well we haven't accepted it because it's
a really poor offer it's rubbish really
it's way below the rate of inflation
members haven't uh well I'll tell you
what if you let me answer we've had a I
haven't had a pay increase for three
years our members during that period
have been subject to an inflation rate
on the retail price index of over 22 and
they've been offered nine percent over
two years but they have to fund that
themselves
through cuts to their their terms and
conditions changes to their working
practices reductions in pay rates
across the industry and of course the
closure of every booking office in the
country and that's unacceptable to us we
should get new money on the table we
shouldn't have to accept all these
changes to our conditions in an industry
that is 24 7. we need proper agreed
rules on rostering and Staffing and
accessibility for people who want to use
our Railway and all these companies are
interested in is maximizing their
profits and what we need to understand
is that since the pandemic they have
made over 420 million pounds in profit
these train operating companies they're
currently running profits at over 118
million pound a year they're paying
their Chief Executives the first group
chief executive had an increase last
year of
it is remuneration his finance officer
had over 150 percent uh increase
remuneration so they are literally fat
cats getting rich on the back of our
members work and the extortion of fares
that the public have to pay while
they're telling us we can't have a pay
rise that's unacceptable
you say it's a it's a rubbish offer nine
percent over two years 13 to the lowest
paid but uh according to the Guardian
newspaper a similar officer has been
given to network rail uh staff there and
that's been put to referendum which
we're expecting to get a result on next
Monday I mean they clearly don't think
it's it's that rubbish an offer if
they're willing to put it to their
workers shouldn't you put it to your
workers anyway and see what your workers
think of it whether or not they think
it's a rubbish offer
well it's an increased offer it's a
better offer than the train operating
companies have made so and the details
are in that offer there's an extra
amount of money and there's back dating
that's in that offer and that's why it's
been put to a referendum those
negotiations have concluded at the
moment we went to our members thousands
of them and did a mass consultation on
the details of this offer and the money
issue wasn't the main priority it's the
conditions and The Ripping up of our
contracts of employment and the dilution
of our terms and additions that has
caused this offer to be stuck so they
need to improve what they want to pay
our members and they can afford that
because of the extortion of profits
they're making from the fair payer and
the taxpayer and they could maintain our
conditions through agreement in
negotiations they're unwilling to do
that because they want to make those
profits even bigger and if you take all
these companies a bellio go ahead and
first group and so on they're nearly all
subject to takeover bids from private
Equity companies because they see that
if they drive down conditions in this
industry they can maximize profit so
there are overseas Equity companies that
want to take these companies over and
and drive up the corporate return for
their dividend holders and shareholders
we don't find that acceptable we want a
balanced deal for our people that
retains their conditions of employment
and gets them a decent pay increase and
that's not on the table at the moment
passengers care about that do not think
passengers just want to be able to get
to work do you think do you think they
mind what the motivation is you're
saying that the motivation for for what
the companies are doing is all money the
companies will say that their motivation
is is to make the businesses run better
but as far as passengers are concerned
they don't care what the motivation is
they just want the trains to be running
and there are there are people who can't
get to work today well I'm here to get
their kids to school today because once
again you're on strike
I'm here at Houston Station and we've
had the most appalling train service
that any Railway company has provided in
history and if you take if you take a
northern Rail and Transplant iron
Express what these companies specialize
in is failure they've proven time and
again that they are incapable of running
the railway so what the passengers want
I believe is a is a decent competent
management system where they can expect
a reliable and safe Railway at a
reasonable price these train operating
companies have succeeded in extracting
profit billions of pounds of profits
into privatization and have totally
degraded our Railway system they haven't
invested a penny all of the investment
in the railway comes from the taxpayer
it goes straight into the hands of
Rolling Stock leasing companies and the
people that lose out of the staff and
the passengers so what we need to do is
get rid of these these middlemen who all
they specialize in collecting dividends
and fares off the off the taxpayer and
get a decent system of Railway operation
which is a square deal for the
passengers the staff and the taxpayer as
well and what we need to do is change
the system because they're all they're
interested in is farming revenue and
paying it out in dividends to their
people and that's what the passengers
should get as a contract from this
government rather than the exploitation
they're currently getting the passage
just want to get to work to just go
about their daily lives and you say that
that customers want to alive
if you speak to everybody
if you speak to everybody in the north
of England at the minute and anyone who
wants to use West Coast Railways they
can't rely on getting to work even when
we're not on strike there's more
disruption when we're not on strike than
where we are in some cases it's an
appalling system and the people that are
running our Railway at the moment have
proven themselves completely incompetent
so what we need to do is get a
settlement to this dispute and then get
on with reforming and restructuring our
Railway in the interest of the public in
the interest of the passenger in the
interest of our economy and our
environment that's what we need to do
that's the task in front of us and that
would start with resolving this dispute
with a decent offer to our members that
we can put to a referendum
you see there are others who will say
that actually because of the number of
strike days they are now considering
different ways of working and ways that
have worked around since covid people
are much happier now working from home
absolutely you know for a lot of the
time and some would argue that you're
actually striking your own way out of a
job because you're going to contribute
to the railways becoming less popular
less reliable people are going to stop
relying on the railways
well I don't think that's true that's a
government line that you're punting out
on their behalf it's not if they come
out excuse me
I'm talking to you about conversations
I've had please I'm not going to have
you stand there and accuse me of being a
government mouthpiece I'm a human being
I'm a middle-aged woman and I'm a
journalist and I'm talking to you about
conversations I've had with people I
know this has got nothing to do with the
government it's exactly the phraseology
that I hear across the table from
government ministers almost verbatim so
there you go maybe you're just very in
tune with what they say so what happened
to the railway we've got okay well I
thought maybe they're in tune with the
government as well so we've got to
return to Railways we've got a return to
profit making by these companies and
we've got to return to Fair hikes so
what we need to do is change the system
we need to get a railway that's reliable
so that people can use it so they can
get back into our towns and cities
revive the economy for the hospitality
industry and all the other people that
rely on the railways and public
transport but what we're seeing now is a
government that's determined to drive
down public transport usage whether
that's on the buses or the railway fares
are being hiked services are becoming
more and more unreliable and the problem
is that there is not a coherent Railway
system in our country it is completely
fractured and broken and we need to
revise that and get a decent system
that's in all our interests
McLean's General Secretary of the nut
thanks for joining us today
well let's take you to Tokyo now we've
got latest pictures of the defense
secretary Ben Wallace he is meeting his
Japanese and Italian counterparts he's
been meeting him over the last few
minutes he's there for a trilateral
meeting I wonder if we may get some
words from him at some point today to
get his reaction to the budget yesterday
11 billion pounds for defense over the
next five years is he pleased with that
is it enough we shall find out hopefully
at some point this morning
now Spanish police say they've recovered
a submarine suspected of transporting
cocaine across the Atlantic
a team of police divers were able to
re-float the submarine and the Guardia
civil then transported The Vessel to the
port of zoofer where it was confirmed to
be empty
curious
you're watching Sky News still to come
82 Premier League goals 47 goals for
England and now 34 years of age will
tell you whose birthday it is after the
break
[Music]
now before the break we asked you to
guess whose birthday it is today and if
you did well done uh it was drumroll
please Theo Walcott the Southampton and
former England footballer turns 34 today
last week he even made the suggestion
that he could retire as early as this
year and pursue a career in journalism
hope his pension pot's big enough uh
also sticking with the birthday theme on
Tuesday we wished Sir Michael Kane a
happy 90th birthday well Eclipse shared
on social media since I showed the actor
celebrating uh his 90th with a
star-studded dinner attended by Tom
Cruise David walliams and Denise Welsh
is not pictured here
strange bunch I hope it was a great day
I'm sure there's been a giggle now one
of the biggest announcements in the
budget is the government's plan to
provide 30 hours of free child care per
week for working parents of a child
under five but for many providers
already facing soaring costs and
Staffing shortages the Chancellor's
measures are not going to be that easy
to deliver with me now is Maggie Bulger
who's the founder and chief executive of
children's daycare provider B together
at Maggie thanks very much for coming in
what did you think when you when you
heard it yesterday I mean on the on the
face of it it's going to take a bit of
time to deliver but it does mean that
for a lot of parents there's going to be
some some subsidized slash free child
care in the coming months and years I
mean from a parent's perspective I think
it's wholly positive from a provider's
perspective I think everyone in the
industry is just going here we go again
you know free is not free for a start
it's funded
and we're in a crisis we're in a
recruitment crisis so to be able to even
provide all of these extra places and
stuff we're all sitting there going okay
so where's the help and support for us
to be able to recruit and to find people
that want to work in the industry
um we don't have them we're in a short
there's a massive shortage year on year
now we've got a decline in people taking
up child care qualifications the
industry doesn't have the best
reputation people don't want to come
into it and people within it from covert
onwards uh going they're leaving us
we're going into hospitality and into
retail
so I think our big question is okay so
how are you going to help us recruit
people to be able to deliver deliver
them well the government says it's going
to give you 30 more money for these
places that must go somewhere towards
helping a 30 more but we've still got a
lot of increased costs we're not just
talking about increased Staffing energy
bills rents rates everything has gone
insane so 30 more also the devil's in
the detail with what the government
always says you know as I said free and
funded is very different to what we
actually get it's a pre
um it's an amount given to settings
depending on where they are in the
country and it's often I think people
are familiar with the term champagne
nurseries lemonade funding
um it's just not enough and I think our
main thing also the main thing in the
sector is recruitment like we don't have
an influx of people anymore so since
brexit we don't have the influx from
Europe so we're relying on a local
market and as I said year on year
there's a decline in people wanting to
take a child care why do you think
people don't look at a career in child
care and think you know that's a great
career I'm getting to spend my time with
with young kids yes they're exhausting
anybody who's had them will know that
but it can also be really really
rewarding it can be a lot of fun it can
be a really rewarding career is it just
the money I think it's a lot of things a
lot it is renowned to be underpaid
compared to teachers
um and primary it is daycare so it's
it's you know schools are term times you
get the holidays this is 360 also days
of the year
um and it should be fun you're right
that's one of my big things when I came
into this industry I set up a day
Nursery because my my youngest child I
was working mum at the time and I was
like right I need to put him somewhere
and it should be fun I design beautiful
spaces to make them really fun and
engaging but there's a lot of
um
it's just a lot of stress and fear in
the industry you know ofsted is a
governing body that is quite fearful and
there's a lot of tick boxing and it's
not fun actually it's quite it's quite
stressful and how we bring the fun back
and how we bring the industry back into
something that is a rewarding career
again is is I think what everyone in in
my industry in particular is trying to
figure out sadly a lot of people that
are massively passionate are leaving
they're selling up now and just saying
we're out
um so it's we're in this Crux at the
moment and it's like how do we Rebrand
child care and make it a rewarding
career again you know and I think the
government's going to have to come to
the party with helping with this because
it is it's a it's a huge industry it's
not it's an industry in crisis and
that's not a term that's been thrown
around Loosely at the moment it is on
its knees okay Maggie Maggie Bulger
really good to talk to you thanks a lot
for coming in and explaining it to us
while we talked to the chancellor in the
last hour still took come in the next
hour I'm going to talk to the shadow
Chancellor Rachel Reeves for the labor
reaction to Jeremy Hunt's budget and his
comments this morning stay with us for
that lots more to come we've got an
action-packed A couple of hours ahead
don't go away
foreign